hey youtubers it's Charlie so a lot of
you are asking me about the next big
four night crossover on DC TV so the
producers just dropped a whole bunch of
information happy Monday
so the good news is is that even though
we haven't even gotten to Knicks season
yet they're already revealing details
about what they're going to be doing
differently from last year's crossover
so it's all great news and there's a lot
of theories about the stories that they
might decide to do because of the
teasers they release so there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video about the
flash be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
so what's happening is is the Andrew
Kreisberg the showrunner on the flash as
well as Supergirl he's kind of like an
executive producer for most of the shows
was talking about this past year's
crossover and how everybody was kind of
disappointed because Supergirl wasn't a
huge part of it like they had a
Supergirl episode and then they had
their crossover it was really just like
a scene at the very end of the Supergirl
episode where Barry and Cisco show up to
grab her then bring her back and then
they start the crossover
[Music]
it better be the right place
because this isn't the right place
someone thought to be more confused
so everyone's like oh they kind of
oversold this four-night crossover they
kept calling it a four-night crossover
but really it was a three night
crossover so they said that the reason
that's going to be different next year
is because it will be a true four night
crossover and they explained does the
only reason that they didn't do like a
true for nigh crossover is because they
actually had to plan it a year in
advance that's how long it took to get
the schedule lined up so that they could
have the actors bounce back and forth
between all the shows it was a
logistical nightmare that they actually
pulled off pretty well but the big
wrench in their plans was when Supergirl
went from CBS to CW they hadn't planned
for that in that show normally shot in
Los Angeles so you couldn't really cross
those characters over in a really big
way but now the Supergirl is being shot
up in Vancouver is like right next to
where they filmed the flash and arrow so
they can just like walk right across the
street whenever they want for a
crossover that's why you're getting that
flash musical episode just because they
shoot in close proximity is way easier
for them to do stuff like that now
whereas previously it was just a
complete nightmare if you wonder why
there are certain characters that aren't
on Supergirl this season - it's because
they went to Vancouver in those actors
are like we're not moving to Vancouver
so the real question I know everyone's
asking now is that if they're going to
do like a full crossover on their
Supergirl episode and she's on a
different earth what are they going to
do about that does that mean that all
the characters from Earth 1 are going to
go to her earth if you didn't know her
earth is called earth 38 just because
that used to be the channel that it was
on CBS was channel 38 and they
affectionately named it earth CBS so
they just changed it to earth 38 when CW
got the show they didn't give that any
spoilers but they did talk about having
Oliver Queen show up on Supergirl like
the alternate universe version of Oliver
Queen we'll just call him the van Dijk
version of Oliver just because Stephen
Amell is resisted it for so long we know
all about the earth two versions of the
characters but there are a lot of people
on cara's earth on earth 38 that we
haven't seen yet and we also haven't
seen earth one cara yet either the one
that's in Barry and Oliver Universe but
they did sort of downplay earth one Cara
showing up so she's like the only person
that they're like yeah we're probably
can do that anytime soon they said that
the alternate universe versions of
characters get pretty crazy in the
writers room because it opens this huge
can of worms because it's like well you
know if you have like 15 different
versions of Oliver which one is going to
be guest starring or if you have like 50
different versions of the flash which
I'll talk about in a second because
that's one of the future crossover
stores that they might end up doing is
is how do you handle all those different
characters when you have them available
at the same time like if Salvatore is a
big problem on the flash this season why
don't they just get 50 different
versions of the flash to all go at them
at the same time like let's all attack
them at once we'll push them into the
speedforce
and we'll cut off this connection using
Cisco's five powers if they did
something like that it would be like a 9
episode season there'd be no more
threats anymore that's why they always
take stuff back when they give
characters really cool powers they're
like ok we have to like D power them a
little bit so that they're not super
overpowered going into next season but
for the meantime until they release more
information when it sounds like bail 2
is they'll just have some of the
characters go to earth 38 during the
first part of the crossover and then
Carl will come back to earth 1 just like
she did during this past year's
crossover so getting into storylines
though I know everybody wonders like
when are they going to combine Cara's
our with our universe so they can just
do like their crisis on Infinite Earths
storylines where everything just kind of
gets smashed into the same universe and
there's like a certain case to be made
for why that's really cool just because
it'd be an amazing story but the big
advantage to having characters that
always exist in alternate realities that
you see every week is that you can do
really weird stuff and you don't
necessarily have to worry about the
other writers handling it like it's
really hard for arrow to keep up with
all the crazy metahuman stuff it's
happening on the flash so they only
referenced it every once in a while but
you see couple times they'll cross over
but if Supergirl wants to do this big
intergalactic story with the daksa
meit's and Montel they don't have to
worry about it on the flash like that's
why the flash isn't talking about alien
invasion every single week but what
about that crossover story so in the
grand tradition of CW crossovers they
tend to favor titles that are really
short so even though they went with the
invasion storyline for their cross
or they called it heroes vs. aliens so
whenever they do from the comics it'll
be a story that involves all those
characters coming together like a big
comic book event and then like the slam
that they'll use to promote it will be
just something really simple and easy to
follow so what are the most easy to
follow big crossover stories that they
could possibly do well Infinite Crisis
is one of the biggest stories but that's
a story all about them bringing the
multiverse back and we already have the
multiverse so they can't do that Final
Crisis is kind of like a story where
Darkseid is able to use the anti-life
equation to take over the world any
sense Batman back in time this is all
these crazy repercussions so it's
probably not a great story for them to
adapt so if they do a big character that
comes to earth if it's going to be like
a single threat then Mongol would
probably the person they go with because
they've already established that Mongol
and wormholes exist and supergirls
universe so that means there's a version
of him in the main earth one universe
but one of the greatest stories I think
they could have a lot of fun with would
be Grant Morrison's Multiversity which
is this really crazy trippy story about
a team of justice leaguers that form
from multiverse characters which is kind
of what we already have already because
Cara's from a different earth the story
for that was really crazy you basically
have this intergalactic group of
parasites known as the Gentry that want
to take over the mind of everybody in
all of creation so all of creation the
multiverse has to team up to fight them
but the problem with that is that in
truth for Grant Morrison Wright's crazy
stories that are really hard to adapt
into movies and TV shows but they make
for badass comic-book stories so what is
like the really simple idea like a
really simple title comic book thing
that happened this past year big
crossover event DC just reinvigorated
their comics is called rebirth so what
if the TV shows did their own version of
the rebirth storyline so I'm not talking
about like completely rewriting their
continuity because that was one of the
goals of DC rebirth was to sort of fix
their continuity just a little bit but
the overarching story was how they
missed all these ten years somebody
stole ten years from the DC Universe so
it becomes this
Watchmen inspired Batman flash team-up
story where they do all this detective
work to find out what dr. Manhattan did
to steal hope from the DC Universe so
they could do a version of that but just
in the way they changed the invasion
comic book storyline they did a much
simpler version and it was fairly
original which is like a few beats from
the comic book they would probably do
the same thing for any other big comic
book arc so let me know in the comments
which storylines do you want them to
adapt for next year's crossover whatever
it ends up being just make sure it
involves all the characters and it isn't
a storyline that they've already done so
like Mangal is big with black mercy
they're probably not going to do another
black mercy episode just because they
did that during Supergirl season one but
the cool thing that they're introducing
on Supergirl right now is the Legion of
super-heroes
so what they might do is they might
choose a Legion oriented story for the
next big crossover if they can ramp up
the thing is they don't actually have to
write the crossover episode till the
fall so like if some big storyline goes
sideways and they want to go in a
different direction
like if Supergirl doesn't pan out the
way they wanted to and they're like okay
Legion isn't something that we're going
to do in the future they can change
their minds down the road they don't
feel like lock-in right now but speaking
of big crossover so there's a couple big
Marvel things that I'll be talking about
later today you guys can let me know
which video you want me to do so I think
I'm going to try and do Marvel Mondays
where I do like one Marvel bonus video
no matter what's happening so they just
tease a Wolverine Hulk hybrid in the
comics I could do a video about that
this is a teaser they released so we can
freak out about that or - I can do a
video about spider-man homecoming in the
kingpin wanting to beat the crap out of
spider-man Vincent D'Onofrio is like
make it happen you know my phone number
like he is so ready to be in a
spider-man movie but there's a number of
different ways they could cross those
characters over it's just a kingpin is
such a big character for spider-man that
you have to do them at some point so let
me know which video you guys want me to
do next in that obviously new flash
episode coming tomorrow there's a bunch
of DC stuff that happened Suicide Squad
even won an Oscar for makeup and hair is
crazy so congratulations to last week's
flash giveaway winner Brandon al kudia
please private message be on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video I'll just
announce the winner when I post my flash
video tomorrow a new Marvel coming in a
couple hours and you guys still have
plenty of time to leave your requests in
the comments before I start working on
it where you wait for that you can click
here for the new guardians of the galaxy
trailer and you can click here for the
trailer for the next set to go to the
flash thank you so much for watching
let's die pop I'll see you guys in the
next video